Bundesverkehrsminister Volker Wissing
will die autobahnverbreitern er ist ja
gewissermaßen der Klima Geisterfahrer
der ampelregierung er sieht die Ampel
deshalb auch immer nur von hinten und
ihm ist das rote Licht deswegen immer
noch nicht aufgefallen dass die Ampel
seit Anbeginn der Koalition in Sachen
Klimawandel anzeigt ein
blindgängerverzeihung Blind Fahrer vor
dem Herrn kein Wunder er befindet sich
ja im Bundesverkehrsministerium auch in
Geiselhaft der Autolobby ich glaube kein
Mitarbeiter des Ministeriums und das ist
das Ministerium bei dem wirklich nicht
geändert werden muss hat nicht schon
Geld von der Autoindustrie bekommen und
wir wissen ja alle wie Geiselnahme
ausgehen die Geiselnehmer werden zur
Strecke gebracht in diesem Fall
erledigen die Verbrenner Fans das
allerdings selbst weil sie früher oder
später den Anschluss an die weltweite
Entwicklung verpassen da ist dann Ende
Gelände Schicht im Schacht oder wie man
in der Autoindustrie eher Passage sagt
da wurde eine ganze Industrie aus der
Kurve getragen aus der verbreiterten
Kurve was die Autobahn betrifft